first big Republican hearing since
taking control of the house about
Twitter and how they backfired
spectacularly and humiliatingly I won't
refresh that story for you but we then
saw the next hearings the committee
looking into the weaponization the
weaponization of government it's hard to
say it with a straight face this is the
Republican attempt apparently to bring
up Hillary Clinton and Hunter Biden
which seems to be that's their Hammer so
everything looks like a nail this
hearing started yesterday with two of
the most electric speakers you can
imagine Chuck Grassley and Ron Johnson
maybe electric is a bit of an
exaggeration and in this first clip
they're talking about Hillary I mean
it's 2023 and they're talking about
Hillary here is Chuck Grassley oversight
of the FBI very important weaponization
of government
um talking about how Hillary Hillary
colluded with Russia in 2016 apparently
to defeat herself this is so Russia
wanted Trump to win
and Hillary colluded with them I guess
to help defeat herself
we all know now that it was a Democratic
National Committee along with the
Clinton campaign who colluded with the
Russians what they used a former Russian
spy reichen Fusion GPS
and Law Firm to create a fake dossier
this is what happens when you're given
notes you don't understand and ask to
read them it sounds like you don't know
what you're talking about Chuck Grassley
was not the only Republican
senator who brought up Hillary Clinton
here is Ron Johnson just on the Vanguard
of the political criticism space
um also bringing up Hillary Clinton my
first investigation ultimately revealed
the extensive editing of then FBI
director James Comey of his July 5th
2016 statement that exonerated secretary
Clinton regarding her use of a private
email server for officials what's the
deal with saying Clinton I really don't
get that anyway so they Ron Johnson
brings up Hillary as well and then it
really wouldn't be complete unless he
also mentions Hunter Biden which he did
prior to the impeachment proceedings
Hunter Biden's obvious conflicts of
interest in Ukraine became public
and Senator Grafton and I began
investigating yeah the idea by the way
it's beyond power this is sort of like
um
this is like your dog investigating who
knocked over the bin that contains the
treats and ate the entire package of
treats that your dog is not going to be
a great investigator of that uh Chuck
Grassley and Ron Johnson investigating
Hunter and Hillary does not seem like
it's going to get you to the bottom of
anything now speaking more seriously
during her opening statement delegate
Stacy Plaskett a Democrat who is on the
committee because remember even though
this is a republican organized committee
Republicans want this committee they you
have Democrats on these committees she
summed up the committee perfectly
listened to what she had to say I'm
deeply concerned about the use of Select
sub Penny as a place to settle scores
showcase conspiracy theories correct and
advance and extreme agenda yes at risk
undermining Americans faith in our
democracy correct some of today's
Witnesses would have us believe that the
Department of Justice and the Federal
Bureau of Investigation are part of a
deep state cabal right one even wrote a
book describing the FBI itself as a
threat to democracy
the Department of Justice and the FBI do
not always get it right history is full
of examples of these agencies getting it
very very wrong we have colleagues in
this Congress who have been subject to
politically motivated hateful racist
investigations by our government yeah so
she completely sums it up perfectly
which is this is another sham committee
it's not really meant to investigate it
is meant to prop up a narrative that
they have already decided as the truth
and to prop it up based on the
pre-existing conspiracy theories and
wild claims that we've been hearing from
these very same people for two four or
even six years so it is yet another joke
and it doesn't seem like it's going to
get any better anytime soon we have some
interesting news on the fight to remove
George Anthony devolder Santos from the
House of Representatives house Democrats
have filed a resolution led by
Democratic Congressman Robert Garcia
to expel yes to expel George Santos from
the House of Representatives
um it is the latest escalation writes
axios of Democrats efforts to public
punish Santos for the serial
Fabrications about his background I I
have not been super familiar with
Congressman Robert Garcia up until now
he has an unbelievable sense of timing
listen to this interview in which he
says you know Santos is a lot like me uh
Latino gay except he lies about
everything this is so funny as an openly
gay person as an immigrant as a Latino I
look at Mr Santos as someone who's
actually very similar to me except that
he lies about everything and So within
within our own lgbtq Community there's
like major disgust in what he's doing
and his representation of our community
and so it's not acceptable for him to
lie about every single part of his past
including uh uh now getting classified
information uh or access to it so it's
just it's time that honestly the final
straw was getting access to giving
accessing and giving access class of
information you're literally getting
some of this a thriving liar
um access to America's Secrets yeah so
of course I agree completely with Robert
Garcia I would not you know if a few of
you emailed me after the story broke and
said David this is such a waste of time
republ applicants control the House of
Representatives there is just no way in
hell that this goes anywhere you know
the you're probably right but it is true
that there are some Republicans who are
disgusted by uh George Santos and
they've said it if Mitt Romney were in
the House of Representatives rather than
the Senate I am a hundred percent sure
that Romney would join Democrats in a
vote to remove George Santos so because
the majority for Republicans is quite
small it is not completely out of the
question that you find that Democrats
find just enough Republicans to maybe
get rid of George Santos do I think it's
the most likely outcome no but is this
worth doing and try to get a vote and
try to get Republicans on the record get
them to say no I vote for Santos to stay
I actually do think it's a good idea in
this particular case now I am not
someone who as a blanket
says symbolic votes in the house are
either worth it or not worth it wastes
of time or good uses of time I don't
have a generic
umbrella view on that I am balancing in
my assessment
is it really guaranteed to be symbolic
only or is there actually a chance that
you might pass it what would we achieve
by putting members on the record by
getting them to vote one way or another
you know when we think back to that
Force the vote Medicare for all thing we
really knew the positions of basically
every every member of Congress on that
issue I actually don't know the
positions of every member of the House
on whether they would vote to keep or
expel George Santos and it actually is a
close enough margin now that it that at
least theoretically it could work I
think this is an interesting idea good
for Robert Garcia good for Democrats
let's see if we ultimately get a vote on
it if you were worried
that since leaving office
Donald Trump was short on grifted donor
money
I want to put to ease put to rest those
concerns Donald Trump has put nearly a
million dollars of donor money into his
own Pockets since leaving office since
leaving office this is based on a
Huffington Post analysis of a new FEC
filing Donald Trump failed to spend much
of the money he raised over the last two
years to win Georgia Senate seats or
fund the Red Wave in 2022 but he did
manage Wright's SV de te for HuffPost he
did manage to put nearly a million
dollars of his donors contributions
right back into his own cash registers
from the day he left office through the
end of 2022 the coup attempting former
president's various political committees
spent 905 thousand dollars at his
properties according to that HuffPost
analysis you don't need to even really
look at the details but when you do you
find hundred thousand dollars in hotel
spending here four hundred thousand
dollars in Camp in hotel spending there
Trump Tower rent offices all of these
different things now the reality is that
even this number of a million dollars
doesn't fully represent the degree to
which Donald Trump is funneling donor
money back into his own Pockets there's
actually a lot of different ways that
this is done one way of course is by
raising donor money and then having
campaign or pack spending be spent at
your own businesses another way is to
pay off your own campaign debts even
when you claim to to be raising money
for something different there are so
many different ways that you can funnel
money that is being donated for
political reasons uh back back into your
own Pockets you can also use your
personal properties and have foreign
dignitaries who visit you as so many did
and stayed at Trump's DC Hotel uh in
order to ingratiate themselves with you
by staying at your hotel which of course
makes you money while you are President
of the United States there's all of
these different ways that you can do it
what we know is that it is a grift and a
scam all the way down and if Republican
voters want him to he's going to do it
again in 2024. we will stay on the
finance story because it's really as big
a story as any of the other stuff the
finance grift scam that Trump has now
run for six years is extraordinary and
he's getting away with it at least for
now all of the clips I played here will
be on our YouTube channel find it at
youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show make sure
you're subscribed
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show is made possible
and funded directly by our audience it
is you it is the people who listen it is
the people who watch and I humbly humbly
humbly ask that you get yourself a
membership at joinpakman.com it's cheap
it's quick to get it feels good and it
comes with great benefits including
access to the Daily bonus show only for
our members commercial free audio and
video streams of the show published
every day hours before we make the show
public invitations to member-only town
halls and also now a new member benefit
access to a web-based version of my
soundboard oh the bonus show where you
want to make money yeah everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad get access to the sound board as a
new member benefit people are loving it
let's hear from some people in the
audience it is great to be back this
week we take calls on Fridays via
Discord at davidpackman.com slash
Discord let's get right to it starting
today with Ty from Iowa Ty from Iowa
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
Ty from Iowa please select the correct
audio device so that we can hear you and
then it is going to be a fantastic
experience for us
and Ty from Iowa unfortunately
struggling very very much with technical
difficulties let's go to Mike from
Florida Mike from Florida please save us
let's hope your audio device is
configured correctly so that we can all
hear you and we can get this going in a
way that makes sense sir welcome
David packman yes can you hear me I can
hear you fine
wow pleasure to speak to you likewise
I guess I had a small observation sure
and if I had any sort of question it
would be what is your perspective on
that when I'm done all right that makes
sense to you sure so
I kind of asked myself in general why
does a person go towards being a
conservative or being a liberal okay
like average person
they tend to gravitate towards one or
the other or be an independent but
like
how can someone watch something like say
Fox News or Newsmax and be drawn into
that
kind of
you know honestly I wasn't prepared for
your question today well this is a great
topic I think I I have a lot to say
about this so there's a couple different
things going on here Mike if I may we
know that there are some differences in
the brains of the average conservative
and the average liberal this doesn't
mean that your brain determines which of
the two you will be but there are some
studies that find that the
um fear centers of uh brains being
larger
predisposes one to be more likely to be
on the political right than the
political left things like maybe
something to do with dopamine like you
watch the person who is having some sort
of freak out on something you know some
contrived social issue and then you as
the viewer are like yeah that's right
and you feel better yeah I don't even
know the mechanism necessarily but it
seems that there's something that is a
physiological thing we also know that
it's very environmental people who were
raised in blue States in left-wing homes
are are mostly likely to be on the left
and people who are raised in in
Republican homes in red states are more
likely to end up being Republican so
there's definitely an environmental
component to it as well be anomalous to
that you know statistic I was raised in
a red home and
purple but Flora is arguably a pretty
red State these days yeah none of these
are hard and fast rules but these are
just predispositions and then thirdly
and this is the really this is the tough
one
sure I believe that those
who do not receive education in media
literacy and critical thinking are way
more likely to fall for what Fox News
and right-wing media sells and are more
likely therefore to end up on the right
that was kind of like what I meant to
get at like Rachel maddowell wasn't on
the air before but I was never like a
super fan Watcher every day just taking
whatever someone on the left says
without a grain of salt but it seems
like the kind of person who would be
predisposed to watching Hannity or
Tucker just unobjectively soaks in what
they say yeah you know for
I don't know maybe just like the
willingness to accept what someone on TV
is saying unpredictably that is
something you can be educated out of 100
yeah so Mike excellent question
complicated topic but I hope I gave you
some insights into it
now wonderful speaking to you have a
good day David all right Mike from
Florida great to hear from you remember
if you want to talk to me your nickname
in the uh waiting area needs to be name
and location and it needs to at least be
plausibly real okay so like it could be
a city or a state or if you're in
another country another country uh let's
go so so like nicknames and single words
and jokes and this type of thing will be
skipped over let's go to Tristan from
Washington Tristan from Washington
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today
Tristan from Washington I've invited you
to join me on the program you do need to
accept it in order to be able to talk to
me
Tristan welcome I
hello hi can you hear me yes you're
cutting in and out but we are connected
which is a good start
that's strange I don't know what the
issue is
um
hi it's good to speak to you again
um I was just wondering like what is
your
what is your view on the Republicans
choosing Sarah Huckabee Sanders to make
the response to the State of the Union
last night
couple thoughts
um and that was on uh on Tuesday of
course you know Arkansas as a state is a
disaster and that's not me using ad
hominems it's just on education on
income on crime on it Healthcare it's
just a disastrous State they have a lot
of real problems and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders has wasted time as Governor
doing things like Banning the teaching
of critical race Theory which isn't
actually being taught so she is quite
frankly an embarrassment but the reason
Republicans may choose her is because
they see her as the prototypical
Republican going forward which is she is
definitely savvier and less cartoonish
than people like Marjorie Taylor green
and Lauren bobert and she's potentially
part of a generation that the Republican
Party sees as being the types of folks
that maybe in 10 years could be
presidential candidates so I think that
that she was chosen because she is seen
by Republican party insiders as exactly
the direction that Republicans should be
going now that's scary but I think that
that's how they see it
yeah no I was gonna I was gonna ask you
about why they didn't chose choose
somebody like Marjorie Taylor green
because it just seemed it seemed like
maybe maybe she is more cartoonish but
it seems like people like her and Lauren
bobert are more a little more relevant
than Sarah Huckabee Sanders I don't know
the data of how many people have
actually heard of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
are what what she's done but it makes
sense to me it listen I think that
Republican I think that the RNC realizes
that people like bobert and green are
widely seen as jokes to the greater
country whereas an Arkansas governor is
sort of a different story there's a that
she seems slightly more serious
yeah yeah
um that makes sense and one other uh
comma question that I have
it's about you know perm limits you had
brought this up on one of your recent
bonus shows
I personally as somebody on the left
I don't really see
the benefit to imposing term limits on
Congress like I I and I think one of the
reasons
that I say that is because it seems to
me
that we're going to have the same
problems no matter who's in office
it just doesn't seem like it's it
I it seems to me like things like
campaign Finance reform could be the
most immediate concern well as I've said
before Tristan we need I'm in favor of
term limits but term limits alone won't
fix the problems we have I believe we
need term limits combined with campaign
Finance reform combined with for
presidential elections going to a
national popular vote combined with
going to some version of single
transferable vote for all elections
that's a lot of stuff but I do see term
limits as one piece of Reform that I
would like to see
yeah no I I'm just against term limits
altogether I I don't see them as being
super valuable I don't I'm actually even
against term limits for president like I
think that constitutional amendment was
kind of ridiculous wow well listen
Tristan while I disagree with you I
respect your right to have that opinion
what do you think of that
yes uh being disagreeing without being
disagreeable I think is the best way we
can put it Kristen thank you for the
call I appreciate it thank you all right
very important uh topics being being
broached today why don't we go next to
Casey from Kansas Casey from Kansas
welcome to the program let's hope and
pray for no technical issues Casey
welcome you're on
oh dear Casey the most likely problem is
you've selected an audio device that's
not valid on your computer
hello can you hear me now I can hear you
oh you can sorry it took me a second
what's going on
I had a question relating to something
that's
been asked in a few of the communities
I'm in recently okay mainly the vosh or
vouch Community is of course yes Ian
vouch
but would you consider the legislation
and the rhetoric from the GOP targeting
trans people to be a genocide in any
sense of the word uh you know these
these things are so fraught because
you can you can contrive and fabricate
some interpretation of so many things
where you could match it up with a
number of different words like for
example genocide speaking colloquially
and I know Casey you're not trying to
gotcha me right it's just like speaking
colloquially
I don't think that those are the right
words that I would apply to the
anti-trans legislation now can I like
can I imagine how someone might make
that connection can I propose to you how
I would do it if I wanted to make that
case you tell me if this is what's being
said
Casey
hello
uh hi okay can you hear me Casey
yeah a little bit I was having a little
bit of trouble okay yeah I think I can
hear you if I had to make the case that
anti-trans legislation is genocide I
would say something like the following
um
trans folks
have a high rate of suicide uh
attempting and suicidal ideation
and when you pass anti-trans bills that
make it more difficult for them to Avail
themselves of the medical or other
services that may help them
you increase the odds that they will
attempt suicide and thus one could argue
that those bills are in a sense a
genocide is is that like roughly the way
one would do it is that how you do it
but also just like the like I don't know
if you could use like the term
legislative genocide or like yeah say
like there was a recent bill that was
proposed that would make it where
you can't do like transitional Health
Care even if you're 26 or under yeah
which is not even 18 like would that be
like genocide at all listen
this is it doesn't seem to me that the
word genocide is neither accurate in its
Spirit nor productive but of course I
can see how somebody might make us a
semantic argument of that kind it's not
really the way I kind of think about
these issues I think is where I would
leave it
okay do you at least think it's like a
dangerous warning sign at least yes and
also like when when a governor requests
a list of people who have transitioned I
think all those things are very
dangerous warning signs
okay well thank you Casey from Kansas
thank you very much I appreciate the
call if you'd like to chat with me make
sure that your nickname and Discord and
the waiting area is your name
and your location very very important
like for example Harris from Atlanta is
going to be invited to be next on today
Harris from Atlanta welcome to the
program
hey David how are you
good how are you I'm doing well um so my
question is how do you think that people
are able to rationalize in their heads
when they hear either a pundit or a
politician say directly contradicting
things often in the same speech or
broadcast or debate or whatever
what what do you mean
so the the two examples I kind of have
uh number one is with the Trump
documents where at the same time they
were planted by the FBI to catch Trump
and that we need to investigate that but
also Trump Declassified the documents
right uh as as president oh yeah yeah
yeah so at the same time and expected to
both be true but they can't both be true
yeah this is um this is a sort of throw
a bunch of crap at the wall and see what
sticks we see there are so many other
good examples of this another one from
the right is they say
um we've got to stop all these lazy
immigrants from coming in and collecting
welfare and they are taking our jobs oh
wait a second are they not working or
are they working so much that there
aren't jobs left for Americans which of
the two things is it or another example
was the January 6th the January 6th
attendees were both completely really
peaceful and it was actually antifa
being violent like wait a second so were
they peaceful or was it antifa being
violent which of the two things was it
yeah I don't think it matters anymore
because right-wing voters haven't cared
about hypocrisy and conflicts and double
standards for a very long time so I just
I just don't I do not think they care at
all
yeah that I I would definitely agree
that is probably the case like I think
it's really that simple
I so I think the the first time like
obviously it's been going on for a long
time this isn't a new issue but like the
first time where I like fully noticed it
within a spat where two statements were
set in this band about five seconds of
each other whereas in the debate between
Trump and Biden where they were talking
about Trump's taxes and he says at this
in the same statement that he pays
millions and millions in taxes but also
the reason he was able to pay so little
in taxes because of Biden's the tax laws
no it's it's insane it's completely nuts
so yeah I mean listen they're gonna keep
doing it until there's consequences to
doing it and right now their voters
don't care so they'll keep doing it
yeah probably
all right my friend thank you there's
Harris from Atlanta
all right there goes Harris very very
powerful stuff
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from a few more people hopefully with
functioning audio devices we take calls
on Fridays via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to try Thai from
Connecticut Ty you know because you're
from Connecticut I have a good feeling
that our connection is going to work
work beautifully are you there can you
talk to me today
okay I can hear you but it's almost like
you're muttering so low that I don't
know what you're talking about
sorry I got it I got a little bit of a
deep voice okay that's I now I can hear
you perfectly
yeah I mean we gotta get this this stuff
straight man what's what's up with your
boy Pete budajos how from
you think he's a favorable candidate in
the wake of like the airline stuff
the railroad stuff
uh I'm not really a fan of his past like
where are you coming from from that end
all right let's go through those what
what about his past are you not a fan of
uh I think that the fact that he comes
from like
and like the corporate realm with the
McKinsey stuff I think that
um
I think that whole when he was mayor
whatever the whole like there's like the
two high-ranking
like police administrator or something
like that and like one was black one was
white I can only the exact story but I
think they were saying like uh the white
guy was saying racist stuff the black
guy had reported documented it or
whatever
and like Pete ended up firing
to a black cop and there's a huge uproar
or whatever
okay I I admit I'm not familiar with
that particular story but okay so
there's a so there's a couple things
what about like the ports thing what
what about it was Buddha judge's fault I
guess
I don't think the
like the Manifest well my understanding
was is that like the railroad workers
the
the pilots
uh were fatigued wait a second what does
this have to do with ports what are you
talking about
when you say ports you mean airports no
no you're talking about the shipping
right the the boats
I mentioned that I mentioned the
Airlines and
um oh and trains you said
and the railroad uh like strike thing
that uh Congress like dismantled uh a
little bit ago listen I'll just skip to
the chase okay as I've said before it's
nice to meet the workers it's not that I
think Pete Buddha judge is the Uber
Progressive it's not that I think he has
a perfect history I've listed Pete
Buddha judge along with others who I
think are sort of a mold that would be
an interesting way for Democrats to go
in the next couple of election cycles
and what I mean by that is they are
younger
they are really really good in media and
debate situations they have a
ruthlessness in terms of their dealing
with Republicans that I think has been
missing for a little bit which I think
would be good and so it's not I've said
before it's not oh I think Buddha judges
the you know God's gift to Progressive
politics it's I think that these are the
types of folks uh I like Jamie Raskin I
like John awesome Katie Porter Gavin
Newsom it's not positive sorry what are
you talking about
who do you think is God's gift to
Progressive politics right now honestly
right I can't think of anybody right now
there's no one really that I'm fanboying
over I have to tell you
all right can I ask one more quick
question what do you think that in this
upcoming presidential election the
Democratic party should be offering
um black Americans
black Americans specifically or just
policy that
we're talking over each other I'm going
to let you go and I'll just answer
offline because I'm having I'm
struggling to get a word in edgewise
um I would like to see if Biden runs for
reelection or if he doesn't and we see a
um a democratic a different Democratic
candidate I want to see
um a tax reform plan
that will actually both simplify the tax
code but will be abundantly clear that
it is good for the middle class and it
will directly attach tax uh the richest
Americans I would like to see a serious
proposal on a paid family uh a paternity
leave paid paternity and maternity leave
um period I would like to see
um something credible and serious on
what is the next step on health care so
it doesn't have to be we're going from
Obamacare to single-payer for everybody
I don't know that that would be credible
I don't know it would pass but I would
like to see another maybe even do it as
like a Medicaid expansion where we again
raise the income level at which people
will qualify fold more people in uh you
know I will outline what my my top wish
list would be
um sometime closer to when the primaries
really get going all right let's speak
to some other people why don't we go
next to a Christian from Edmonton
Christian welcome to the program what's
on your mind today
David yes sir yes a tear dreaming down
my face right now you're in tears now I
know it right now uh first of all I just
wanted to address a critical issue from
the bigly news a few weeks ago
um I finished your physical over the
weekend and I wanted to get right into
the knit and gritty for you and all your
valuable listeners yeah you are
currently six foot three inches tall and
239 pounds just like Trump it's shocking
yeah
big big strong man
you also passed the Montreal cognitive
IQ test like nobody else even knew was
possible
somehow the tiger nor the elephant
stumped you yeah okay I also found that
if you didn't go to Starbucks when you
were heading home from Montreal yeah
that last time you could probably have
lived to 600 years old yeah I do think
I'm sorry for that you know I know
you're kidding I do think that that one
Starbucks stop over the last 20 years
probably did hurt me in some way and in
all seriousness Christian
people know it's been 20 years since I
went to Starbucks or Dunkin Donuts in
the last year due to extenuating
circumstances I've gotten a coffee at
both it was terrible it really is
terrible and I'm trying to have an open
mind I'm not trying to be like a third
wave coffee snob or anything like that
the Starbucks coffee was terrible and
the Dunkin coffee was terrible it was
just horrifyingly bad coffee
I mean that's the benefit of having your
own home set up right yeah you set the
bar too high for everywhere you go I
know it I know it but anyway uh was
there anything else you had for me today
yeah um I just want to say congrats on
being a dad it's it's great progress um
my my boy is about two years old now and
it's super cool so I'm excited for you
to see see your daughter yeah the
sleeping is getting much better we're
now she can push like for a 12-hour
sleep you know and she's only she's not
even she's eight months so I think that
that bodes well for the future hopefully
anyway
yeah developmentally as well that's
going to be big big steps that she's
gonna go through so that's awesome to
hear all right well thank you Christian
I appreciate the clean bill health
thanks David all right there is
Christian from Edmonton why don't we go
next to Chris from Philly Chris welcome
to the program what is on your mind
today
Chris from Philly please accept my
invitation sir
and Chris you're currently self-muted
hello yeah now you're on
okay uh I already have something
planning to ask you but to piggyback off
the one thing that one guy said I would
like to see from Biden for the black
community
as to hold Banks feet to the fire for
the
back curding
of red line that they're doing
um
absolutely I agree with that
oh I got customers coming in so I
gotta hurry up the other thing I wanted
to say was
Marty Taylor green on the uh home Home
Security
yeah I mean what's the name
the homeland security problematic yeah
it's really problematic for the simple
fact that she was sitting there chasing
down Parkland shooter uh survivors yeah
oh I got customers coming in Chris what
kind of work do you do what kind of
customers are these
uh I'm a manager at the bear distributor
there's two of my employees called out
today so I'm working by myself at where
where are you
a beer distributor oh a beer I thought
you said that Baron stained bears and I
was like what are you talking about
Chris a beer distributor all right very
good well Chris listen I'll let you get
to the customers okay
all right hit you back later have a good
one all right yep text me later all
right okay uh man a lot of crazy crazy
stuff going on today let's go to ifti
from Germany ifti from Germany welcome
to the program what is on your mind
today
hello can you hear me yes I can
excellent you actually got a three in
one actually I'm in Israeli doing a PhD
about populism on Japan in Germany so
let's uh here I'm increasing your
International uh uh cut of the of the
pie today I guess have you seen have you
seen the fourth season of fauda
uh I'm not a big fan of of fauda or wow
I know I also hate olives I'm I'm
ruining everything for all Israelis I
guess all right well I I can I recommend
it to you it's it's a great season 50
but go ahead okay uh I'd like to
actually make one small comments in one
of your previous uh uh commentators
because um first of all I'm a big fan of
you in general uh just get together the
way uh he spoke about Pete butterjudge
and why is he electable and I've noticed
it's something that you've discussed a
couple of times I'm I'm not a big fan of
this whole argument that he's not
Progressive enough because I I'm myself
I'm a Social Democrat and I'm
considering myself on the left of of him
to an extent okay um but at the same
time
I think you need to look at the field of
who's the most electable and who has a
very good shot and then as like you said
the means and and package uh to win the
presidency and out of those at least in
my view
um if he is elected president he will
probably be the most Progressive
president in the history of the United
States I agree with that 100 percent
reminds me a bit of uh the discussion
about Elizabeth Warren doing the less
primaries that uh after she a couple of
her statements a lot of the people who
are supporters of Bernie uh kind of
clearly says her for not being left is
enough and she I think ideologically
she's not to the right of senders uh in
terms of policy and she is probably the
most leftist senator in living memory uh
or most Progressive in terms of social
democracy well there's Bernie
but together with him they're probably
the most Progressive and if arguably the
most Progressive Progressive senator in
living memory is not Progressive enough
for you as a candidate
I think this is possibly a bigger
problem 50 you're making a very good
point that this is a very good point
which is while on Paper Pete Buddha
judge may not be the most Progressive
person in the world if he were president
he would be the most Progressive
president in history that's very I I I
find it hard to argue against that I
think you're completely right
okay
um about the main thing I have two
questions I hope to get them through one
of them is more Technical and one of
them I'm just interested in your opinion
sure uh I'm wondering about the
um the deficit ceiling and the
discussions about it you have all these
discussions on how uh catastrophic and
apocalyptic it will be if the
Republicans will not raise the debt
ceiling yes to my understanding it's
more of a technical issue uh and the
Republicans at the end of the day they
only have a very slim majority uh of
four or five people I have very very low
um expectations of the Republicans but
to say that you would not find four to
five Republicans out of all House
Republicans who would not be willing to
side with Democrats just to do the
technical
um effect of raising the debt ceiling it
sounds very implausible to me it sounds
like more of a talking point than
something that's realistic I'm wondering
if I'm missing something on the
technical level there you know I I don't
know I don't know if you would be able
to find four or five I mean it's really
it's a predictive question it would be
something we're just guessing about I
don't know who the four or five would be
but it's certainly possible that you're
right
okay uh the last thing again I'm
wondering about your opinion
um as as a person who's ideologically a
Social Democrat for for many years now
I'm wondering how do you deal with
talking points from your own sides that
they don't really make that much sense
and every rational person from your side
that you're tackling with them would
probably acknowledge that they don't
make sense but they're it's it's kind of
a taboo to to bring them up because it's
it's against the cause of of your side
like what I'm gonna give you two two
examples
um one of them if you perhaps know a
little bit about uh what's going on with
the um nursing strikes in the UK at the
moment
that there are all those correct
arguments that the nurses there had
their wages eroded and that they're
being overworked and all of those things
which are completely supporting but one
of the talking points there which is
repeating is that uh NHA workers are
forced to go to food banks yeah and the
median income of an NHS worker in the UK
to my understanding is about 40 000 a
year
40 000 pounds
for forty thousand dollars it's about 32
to 34 000 pounds a year okay and
um
I mean it's
it unless you're a single parent living
in London uh I don't really see how this
kind of seller Which is far above there
looks like the median or above the
median wage in the UK would mean that
you will have to go to food banks now if
you are a single uh a single uh bread
maker living in London it's not really a
a systematic issue it's it's a specific
problem with their wages in London for
single parents another example is the
debate about the minimum wage in the
United States which I'm always very
confused about you have these talking
points going from I think 2008 about 15
uh minimum wage
um and to me it's even if you look at
inflation over the last
um two years or less year even this
should have changed dramatically so this
insistent of selling this talking point
of 15 minimum wage
it it doesn't really make any sense
because it it it's not relying on
anything like an index of living or some
kind of system to keep wages affordable
other than selling this talking point
which which sells I got you I got it
yeah listen these are uh fine examples I
I don't know enough about food stamps in
the UK food banks in the UK to be able
to weigh in too much I think on the
minimum wage thing it's a very fair
point that the fifteen dollars that was
talked about three years ago is a lot
less money in purchasing power terms
because of the inflation of the the last
three years I completely agree let me
devote some more thought to it okay
okay I appreciate it there is ifti from
Germany and that is going to do it for
us today we will take calls again on all
of the important issues that the fine
folks in the audience bring to me I will
speak to you soon we'll take a quick
break and be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's get into the mailbag boy was it a
special treat to get back from my week
off and hear from so many people Furious
that I ever take time off and also from
people who were glad I was gone now to
the people who were glad I was gone you
know you don't have to watch my content
when I'm not on vacation you can just
not watch it and that's totally allowed
and acceptable but let's get to some
marginally more substantive stuff
starting as we sometimes do with an
adversarial comment I don't run away
from these Stephen wrote in and said
you're awoke Lefty but your was the
wrong your almost a requirement at this
point you're awoke Lefty joke should be
banned from social media for pushing the
lies of the democratic party
you're paid by them the wrong you're
again
and as we sometimes do we respond simply
with y o u apostrophe r-e I maintain my
challenge I have been accused of being
paid for by the Democratic party of
globalists uh I've been accused of being
paid for by the Democratic party George
Soros Bill Gates big Pharma whatever
for over a decade and I still am waiting
for anyone to present some evidence of
that
and uh it's an open invitation info info
davidpackman.com if you have that
evidence please send it to me Jason
wrote in about the forthcoming
children's book we are working on Jason
says David the word critical should
appear nowhere in your children's book
if you use that word your book will be
banned in many places I suggest using
media literacy rather than critical
thinking in these discussions at least
where the audience is likely to be media
illiterate I do agree
that such
value-neutral terms as critical thinking
and actually media literacy as well
have become weaponized by the right who
say uh oh media literacy that's liberal
indoctrination it is true that the more
media literate people are the less
likely they are are to fall for these
right-wing tropes and ideas that is
absolutely true but that's because
they're learning to think for themselves
not because they are being indoctrinated
uh and Jason is probably right more info
on the forthcoming book very very soon
Lizzie wrote in I asked should I cover
these bogus house coveted hearings that
Republicans are planning to have
Lizzie Roden and said no please don't
cover the hearings live it totally
legitimizes them and there's so many
people who come to your page also
judging by some of the emails and
voicemails people seem to hate when you
talk or comment over proceedings anyway
I know can you imagine if what my show
was is I take the C-SPAN feed of a
hearing
and I sit there like a piece of wood or
clay or metal
um for the three hours and don't say a
word like no nobody's coming here for
that go to C-SPAN if that's what you
want Lizzy I appreciate you pointing out
the absurdity of that
uh who else wrote in Jeremy wrote in
about Trump anti-vaxxers and 2024.
Jeremy says from Chicago hey David love
your show I have thoughts on Trump and
anti-vaxxers I believe Trump won't win
the 2024 primaries if he is still in
support of the covet vaccine more and
more of his Ardent supporters hate the
vaccine and the vaccinated most recently
silk from diamond and silk Trump knows
his base hates the vaccine and he needs
to change his tune in order for him to
have a chance at winning the 2024
presidency let me know your thoughts
yeah I mean listen Jeremy you're not
wrong that it's a little hard the mental
gymnastics required for
praise me for the great job I did
developing the vaccine
which
might be really bad for you and you
should have the freedom not to take and
it should never be mandated and it's a
beautiful lovely Freedom thing for
people not to get vaccinated
that I got all three doses of speaking
As Trump now or however many doses he's
up to
but praise me for it but don't get it it
is a really difficult place to be in and
the reason it's particularly difficult
for Trump is he doesn't have many
accomplishments to speak of from his
first term I mean he he claims
accomplishments they're mostly lies and
so he needs stuff to to brag about
the vaccine stuff is not seen as an
accomplishment by many of his followers
I don't know what he's going to do how
he will position that in 24. uh but
it'll be interesting to see Alex wrote
in about the double standards of the
right and says hey David wanted to point
out Republicans were accusing Obama of
lying about his childhood where he was
born Etc despite no evidence of this
meanwhile they are A-Okay with Santos
who has been caught in multiple lives of
a somewhat similar nature the right has
so many double standards ironically
they have absolutely no standards for
who they actually elect with all due
respect Alex Alex you said it so
perfectly
I couldn't possibly add anything to it
you are completely correct
Stephen wrote in about Michael Cohen's
show Maya culpa
saying I wanted to mention to you
Michael Cohen has repeated numerous
times in his show that you go to
different Trump rallies and events
interviewing people to show the irony of
their positions I know you've
highlighted some of these interviews in
the past but I'm fairly certain you're
just quoting or replaying these from
other sources that aren't produced by
your show directly I thought you might
want to correct them unless I'm mistaken
yeah it has been brought to my attention
multiple times that Michael Cohen who's
a friend of the show thinks I go to
Trump rallies it is true that I don't go
to the Trump rallies
but we do have our correspondence and in
particular Luke Beasley who does go to
the event so we are generating original
content at those rallies but it is true
that I'm not the guy who goes to them if
I have the opportunity to correct uh
Michael I will Brian wrote in about
socialism socialism Brian says hello
David I want to ask a question about the
term socialism as Paul Krugman once
suggested in regards to Bernie using the
term socialism gives any opposition The
Leverage to compare one to Stalin I've
heard you stayed on your show that there
are no real socialists in government and
I tend to agree
when I listen to your views on
government economy health care I think
you're pretty reasonable however do you
agree that left-wing politicians and
pundits and influencers should distance
themselves from the term I don't expect
you to be responsible for others but I
think it's fair criticism to point out
that people like Kyle Kolinski and
vausch turn people off of actual issues
with their abstract understandings and
glorification of socialism okay I don't
know I can't speak to Kyle and vouch Ian
Bosh however you know him
here is should people distance
themselves from the term socialism
if you are really a socialist
then you should embrace the term because
that's really what you are to the extent
that the Democratic Party
really doesn't have socialists in it
in positions of power I don't think
anybody who isn't actually a socialist
should embrace the term because it's
both inaccurate and not advantageous now
I know that there's polling that says
well young people are less negative
about socialism than ever before
young people specifically and less
negative doesn't to me signal that it's
a winner
to say we are socialists when we are not
my general view is
in particular if you're not really a
socialist don't embrace the term and
this I think has been one of my biggest
criticisms of the way Bernie ran his
campaigns
uh
let's call ourselves what we are I am a
Social Democrat that's a regulated form
of capitalism and I will repeat it as
many times as I need to repeat it in
order to get that across we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today
please sign up at joinpakman.com we do
directly depend on the support of people
who get memberships at joinpakman.com I
would love for you to be one of those
people we will see you on the bonus show
and then back here next week
foreign